[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a 2018 rom-com film called
i'm not an easy man
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
damian is a shameless chauvinist who
works for a male-dominated marketing
agency he proudly uses all the benefits
of living in a patriarchal world to his
advantage he likes dominating women he
meets and treats them like objects for
his pleasure damien's boss marco loves
him and always gives him the important
projects and assignments he has a close
friend and neighbor named christoph
lamey who's a famous writer one day
during chris's new book's launch damian
meets his new attractive assistant
alexandra he is dating a woman named
sybil but that doesn't stop him from
flirting with other women he hits on
alexandra but she finds his chauvinist
attitude off-putting and turns him down
when chris's pregnant wife lolo arrives
with their two children damien and sybil
ask her if they can come over for dinner
to celebrate chris's book launch however
lolo is in a bad mood and she turns them
down saying she can't have guests over
on a school night damien and chris
quickly realized that lolo is upset
because chris forgot her birthday again
after lolo leaves with the children the
two friends go out to buy flowers for
her like his typical self damien makes
passes at random girls on the street
while whistling at a girl damian gets
distracted and hits his head on an
electric pole knocking himself
unconscious when he opens his eyes again
he finds a female medic tending to him
after collecting himself damien meets
sybil and lolo who are going out
together the latter asks chris to take
care of the children before departing on
the way back home damian complains about
feeling cold and says he feels that his
jeans are too tight chris speculates it
could be because of his sagging balls
and suggests that he should get a
cosmetic procedure to fix it damien
laughs off the suggestion thinking it's
a joke but little does he know that
chris is dead serious
back at his apartment damian puts on a
warm muffler and a packet of cold peas
on his head he watches tv to entertain
himself but for some reason he sees that
every show on tv is objectifying men
instead of women the next morning damien
wakes up and proceeds to get ready for
work but to his astonishment he only
finds short and bright colored clothes
in his closet he puts on some grey
sweatpants a tight white t-shirt and
heads to work at work he notices that
most of the employees are now women who
make inappropriate comments about his
body and appearance damien's co-worker
sophie takes him to her office and tells
him that the company didn't choose his
project she calls his humor delicate and
tells him that the clients want more
feminine and crude humor therefore a
female employee got the gig damian is
surprised and asks to speak with marcus
however when marcus arrives damian is
stunned to see him serving coffee damien
flips out and tells sophie that she is
making a very big mistake by not
selecting his project enraged sophie
tells him to calm his hormones before
firing him puzzled and confused damien
goes to a bar where he notices two men
wearing veils he freaks out and runs to
his parents eatery there he sees his mom
mincing the meat as his dad entertains
the customers upon seeing damien his
father starts bothering him about
settling down while his mother comes to
his defense the world seems to have
turned upside down freaked out damien
goes back to the electric pole from
earlier in the movie and bangs his head
on it hoping to teleport back to the old
world but without success
that night he meets sybil for drinks at
the bar sybil orders a beer instead of
champagne and scantily-clad men
entertain the patrons but damian seems
to have started to wrap his head around
this new world sybil then goes to
damian's apartment to have intercourse
but she is put off by his hairy chest
and storms out damien shares his work
dilemma with chris and lolo who advise
him to seek the help of a masculist
group that fights discrimination against
men at work lolo then suddenly goes into
labor and she is rushed to a hospital
where she gives birth to a baby while
hanging by a bar chris's boss who is
revealed to be alexandra isn't happy
that he is taking a paternity leave
however chris promises her to find
someone to take his place and an out of
work damien jumps at the opportunity
before sending damien to work for alex
chris gives damian a makeover he cuts
his hair threads his eyebrows shaves his
armpits chest hair and also the hair
down below a booty shorts wearing damien
then goes to work for alex who is a
dominant seductress and successful
writer alex lives in a fancy house and
she seems to be fond of collecting
marbles when she sees damien she notes
that he is tall and makes him make
coffee for her she then gives him a list
of things to do before heading out
damien meets her housekeeper martell who
showers praise for her and says only
women can write good novels which
offends damien after doing menial jobs
all day damien gets fed up and when alex
returns he tells her that he is not cut
for this job and world when he tells her
that he can't live in a world where
women dictate what he does alex tells
him to save his masculist rant for
someone else for comfort he calls sybil
to have intercourse only for her to
leave him disappointed when she finishes
before making him climax fed up with
this matriarchal world damian and chris
join a masculist group called tit for
tat the group is known for wearing fake
boobs and organizing protests against
matriarchy meanwhile it strikes alex
that a masculist character for her new
book could be revolutionary and she
starts writing her book using damien as
an inspiration damien receives a text
message from alex and decides to meet
her after his father keeps pressuring
him to settle down at the bar alex tells
him that the world he keeps talking
about is interesting she says that it is
not so bad for women as they receive
gifts and have men hold doors open for
them excited damian enthusiastically
tells her about the patriarchal world
over drinks
after having a few too many drinks in
his system damian tries to make out with
alex but she tells him that she doesn't
take advantage of drunk guys and sends
him back home in a cab it is revealed
that alex had recorded her conversation
with damian which she takes to her boss
annie meyer the next day alex tells her
that she wants to show the world that
even masculists are dependent on women
she plans to get damian to fall in love
with her so she can eventually break his
heart and teach him a lesson annie loves
the idea and asks to see the writing
sample on her desk as soon as possible
as alex continues to court damien he
tells chris that he can no longer work
for alex because he is dating her this
upsets chris because he is afraid that
he won't get his job back after his
paternity leave ends the two get into an
argument and damian brings up the fact
that his wife doesn't respect him upset
chris tells damian to never talk to him
again alex and damian spend more and
more time together and eventually have
intercourse unbeknownst to damien she
even records them having it alex takes
her to work parties and even introduces
him to annie during their time together
alex continues to have intercourse with
other men one of whom vandalizes her
home for using him meanwhile blinded by
love damien irons her shirt and runs
errands for her chris eventually
forgives damian when chris tells him
about lolo's unfaithfulness damien
comforts him and promises to be by his
side no matter what meanwhile alex
always makes it a point to hide her
writing samples from damian which only
makes him more curious he asks to see it
but she changes the topic and asks him
to work for her damian turns down the
offer saying he's applied to work at a
bar because he doesn't want to be
dependent on her he says he wants to be
equal to her which irritates her one day
a man named daffodil shows up at alex's
place unannounced while she is away
daffodil seems upset and forces his way
into alex's bedroom worried damien texts
alex who tells him to call the cops on
him daffodil spray paints small tits on
her bedroom wall and tells damien that
the marbles on her shelf represent each
of her male conquests a tearful daffodil
tells him that she made him feel smart
and worthy only to then make him feel
like a fool in the end damian is taken
aback by the revelations and he
confronts alex about the marbles he asks
her if he is also just another marble to
her alex refuses to take responsibility
and gaslights him instead an upset
damien then leaves
damian starts seeing a therapist
meanwhile alex submits her first sample
to her publisher who loves it and tells
her she can't wait to read the rest
however alex has started to have doubts
about the novel as she feels it's cruel
she suggests new novel ideas to annie
but annie turns them down and orders her
to finish the rest of this one after a
lot of deliberation alex decides against
writing the novel and tells this
decision to annie meanwhile chris kicks
lolo out of the house and she crashes at
damian's apartment lolo reveals that she
cheated on chris while she was pregnant
and her hormones were raging she regrets
cheating on him and asks damian to
convince chris to take her back alex
makes amends and returns back to
damien's life he doesn't waste time in
proposing marriage to her and to his
astonishment she accepts the proposal
damian and his father convince chris to
forgive lolo damian also tells his
father about alex the next day damian
and chris join the masculist group tit
for tat in protesting against a french
college for only honoring female writers
at the venue damien meets annie who
recognizes him when annie smugly asks
him if he has nothing better going on in
his life chris proudly tells her that
damian is actually getting married to
alex damien taunts her saying some women
are more open-minded than others however
annie snatches the smile and pride out
of his face when she tells him that alex
is already married stunned by the
revelation damien rushes to confront
alex when he finds her door locked
damian tricks martel into giving him the
keys to her apartment after gaining
entry into her home damien goes through
her belongings and finds her marriage
certificate hurt he goes full daffodil
and trashes her room meanwhile alex is
at her husband's place to pick up her
daughter before departing alex tells him
that she is filed for divorce and this
time he must sign the papers alex then
returns home with her daughter and she
learns from martel that damian had
dropped by when she enters her home she
finds the entire place trashed alex
notices her writing samples on the floor
and realizes that damon has found out
about the novel a worried alex looks for
damien everywhere meanwhile chris gets a
call from his friend erica who tells him
that damian is drunk out of his mind at
her bar and some girls are harassing him
lolo and chris then proceed to rush to
the bar outside their apartment they
meet alex and tell her about damien alex
follows them to the bar where an old
woman is trying to take advantage of a
young damien lolo fends off the old
woman's friends while alex finds the old
woman knocked unconscious on the ground
worried she rushes by damien's side but
he pushes her away alex admits her
mistake and comes clean about the novel
and the recordings but this makes damien
even more upset because he only found
out about the marriage and not the novel
and recordings feeling cheated damien
slaps her alex tries to explain herself
but the two accidentally headbutt each
other and knock themselves unconscious
alex then wakes up in an ambulance being
tended to by male medics she rushes out
of the ambulance and notices that she is
in a patriarchal world the streets are
filled with raunchy advertisements that
objectify women the movie ends as she
notices a feminist march and among its
participants is damien who calls out to
her
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching